another week is on the books I know yeah
Jamison left Co is ready for your ear
drew you are ready we are ready big show
we're gonna talk about how are we
supposed to talk about Andy Dalton we're
gonna talk about oh you're going to to
Jameis Winston that's interesting we're
gonna talk about Earl Thomas's middle
finger Sims douve into the Titans are
they for real at three to one yep
the Pats Dolphins game right a little
self scouting for Sims how to get that
one wrong yeah and then a little tribe
escy because man when you throw six
touchdowns we got to talk about you how
was your weekend it was good notre dame
continues to ride man it must be sims
ever since you got there Notre Dame
who's been good football pretty much
pretty much nothing I could say it's
when they see me on the corner of the
field they just go that Sims guys here's
again we better raise all those guys
here's again here's again honestly we
running back coach we were just talking
for 20 minutes about if I were to I'm
gonna ask all the listeners at the same
time yes everyone that's listening
what kind when you ask for a stake how
do you answer it I'd say that 90% of you
said medium-rare and I went to some
people today bleach reported I said I
prefer it medium well yeah and one of
them called me a psychopath and one of
them called me a serial killer and the
rest said it's a disgrace to meet and I
Quinta Sims and you said I agree with
you first of all a serial killer would
more say to the medium medium-rare guy
color like blood like I we like it
cooked so it's actually not still
bleeding yeah so I I don't get that
night I have a feeling that a lot of
listeners are gonna get very upset at us
how dare you disgrace the meat well and
I said this if we're at a really nice
restaurant then I might do a medium-rare
but most of these other restaurants
there's no lying in Kobe beef I'm not
what it's I want my meat oh there's no
[ __ ] way I'm getting medium-rare in
any restaurant I don't care if it's the
greatest steak place in the history of
the planet it cost $1,000 for a New York
Strip I'm not no one know it's not beef
right but - what's what's your main
reason what do you tell people because
I'm sure you get weird I'd looked at
although I feel like you're the guy that
goes medium well I know I know
I
you say that you know but it's gone it's
it's actually even gone off step further
now because I would say first of all you
know like Friday night date nights
usually my steak night and I can't wait
to get after actually at a steak last
night on Sunday night medium-well yo
yeah probably well and I
I literally have gotten to the point
where and my wife would tell you this I
would say that the last 10 times I've
been in a steak place I asked for medium
well and I still get it medium so the
last few times I've said well done and
they look at me like I'm crazy and I got
a medium well and that's the way I like
it cooked I don't really give a damn
I am eat to live I don't live to eat
my question is how did it become part of
society that that is the only socially
acceptable temperature of meat and and
that cooking meat is is that it's you're
against the your communist communist but
and I don't know commies can make a
little well-done that's an interesting
fact I didn't know yeah it's it's as
though there's artistry in the timing of
the cooking I don't know I like a little
pink okay does that mean well no that's
probably medium I like a medium yeah if
it's a thin line of pink I think that's
medium well it's real thin line but if
then if you get to the bigger part of it
being red or whatever then it's then
you're getting in the medium range
alright so hit us up at said your body
your body body is not gonna digest that
as well that uncooked meat like there's
a reason I see a lot of people on that
like Paleo diet like oh I just have meat
and vegetables yeah and they go but your
belly still big yeah like like I'm not
trying to knock it I'm just saying like
there's a breed I tried to have this
conversation my brother-in-law uh-uh
yeah just to be like no you have like
you have like a 10 pound steak stuck
somewhere in your stomach and I just
write and that's why if you listen to
the radio or Sirius XM and some of those
things they have these pills now to get
the sludge out of your stomach and I
want to be like yeah that's called rare
meat stuck in there alright so that's a
little help but yeah I we went down
there I knew you'd know it's it's rare
yeah I think it's still rare it's still
fresh for Earl Thomas I want to go
because to me of all of the images of
the weekend of success and a failure the
image of Earl Thomas on a cart realizing
that his season is over flicking off his
own team is something that I'm never
gonna forget now I have never even
thought of a guy that was like trade me
or pay me right skipped all the
practices all the meetings was getting
fined still was having a great year yeah
really like he really was huh and then
gets carted off and flips the bird to
the other team or to his own team yeah
Wow I mean it was wild that's how we do
it in Texas we go out gangster style but
first of all I feel for him that was a
tough injury I still I don't know how we
got her exactly right I did watch to
play like four or five times and there's
nothing to see right and it's very odd
so it's just you know unfortunate
whatever it may be again I'll go back
where the players podcast and hey like
there's no way the steal there's no way
the seahawks like kind of a check but by
the way here's five million dollars for
your trouble yeah no no that's what I
mean and that's my argument to us being
the players podcast you know I always
hate out you know coaches always need
did I can't go on a lame-duck season but
when the star player asked to that oh no
you gotta earn this next contractor
you're getting old and we're not sure
but he's not flipping off the team right
I mean he's not flipping off the players
let's just say that who do you think who
do you think he was making - I mean it's
two people
it's either John Schneider the GM you
think he was like on the side or Pete
Carroll it's one of the two so you would
weigh the odds are he was making eye
contact with Pete Carroll when he
flipped the bird I think so I would be
mine be my money for sure somebody that
had to do with the negotiations or the
fact that the Seahawks drew the line in
the sand
and that's what he was given one thing
to won't even look at if you're out
there listening go back and look at the
video when everyone's shaking his hand
on the back of the cart when he gets on
the Cardinals players the Cardinals not
even the Seahawks he like will not look
at Pete Carroll when Pete Carroll comes
over if you really notice he tries to
never look at Pete there was some
different things I look at when he had
an interception in the Bears game yeah
no he had two picks and one cowboy
cowboys gray Pete Carroll came over to
him and I turn to someone go he's not
celebrating with Pete Carroll no no he's
just walking by him he's not gonna
disrespect him I'm willing to say that
he totally flipped off beat Karen I
would think that's who it is and I'm
totally willing to say that was his last
game as a Seattle Seahawk and what's
even crazier do you think about I'm
flipping off Pete Carroll though how do
you think Pete Carroll's thinking I
think Pete Carroll is he's like he gets
it I I think he's not gonna he's not
gonna take and he's kind of sticks up
forward today like he understands where
the players you come from that's one
thing I like about Pete Pete is not like
anti player he tries to put himself in
their shoes but it's also a business and
that's the tough thing you're gonna say
it's definitely his last game as a
Seahawk oh and I just I know you and I
we had the little text last night like
what is it with that field in the
Seahawks they had a few people here are
jinx there someone so that's where kam
chancellor got hurt Richard Sherman
that's where Richard Sherman his last
game as a Seahawk and what else another
big moment in their career don't tell me
dude big game like one of the biggest
games they ever played I don't know big
is game Super Bowl that were the
Marshawn Lynch right does that feel
Phoenix Arizona Wow yes
the only Darrell Bevell special Wow was
all that one they're like they're hexed
in that place well luckily they're done
with it for the season I got the win
right Bobby Wagner came out and said if
he doesn't come then he's not a team
player if he does come and gets hurt
then it's he shouldn't have came if I if
I was him I'd be pissed off too
yeah so Bobby Wagner got it Bobby you I
don't know so ESPN posted that mm-hmm on
Instagram Le'Veon Bell commented
underneath you haven't seen this not at
all he wrote sure going here though
shake my head exactly get right bro bro
Earl Thomas yeah I'll continue to be the
bad guy for all of us good and he
capitalized all and this is really the
larger statement is that we're gonna
forget about Earl Thomas as the season
goes on and Earl Thomas I get it he's a
warrior he wants to go out there he
wants to play at the same
he wants to get his checks and Le'Veon
Bell is being painted by everybody as
the [ __ ] he's the bad guy turning
down money fighting for it
James Connor nine carries 19 yards last
night but levy ons doing really what
we've always wanted which is to go I'm
not doing this I'm not taking it I'm
standing up cuz I don't want to get hurt
and cost my money in the long exactly
the bad guy no long-term security out
running back yeah he's being the bad guy
but really what he's doing is he's going
to save a generation of football players
through this this is gonna become a
thing you think it's gonna be that much
of an ink that this can be enough of an
impact to where at least the owners
think about maybe we have to do this
differently next time around at the CBA
I'll say this much like everyone has
asked me about Pittsburgh all the time
like like they're missing their best
player or one of their best players
people come here they go what's wrong
with it's wrong with Pittsburgh I mean I
don't know you know what's what's wrong
with the Raiders defense they're missing
Khalil Mack you know what what's wrong
with any team that's missing their best
player at like a certain position let
alone
you could argue he's the best player on
their football team right I mean who the
best players on there it's him Antonio
Brown you know hey che zere's gone so he
was another really good player that was
Stefan to it right exactly so let me on
bail the position he played the offense
of style they want to play right that's
the big thing if you want to know what's
going on with the Steelers right now is
Le'Veon Bell is one of the biggest
mismatches in football do I think he's
one of the best running backs in
football of course I don't think he's
the best I think I said I was number
four but so what he's amazing regardless
and you're seeing James Connor can do
that and his skill set in the pass game
and all the runs that we might have not
gone that wasn't that great but it led
them to second and four it's like an
it's like the absolute lowest sean mccoy
left the Eagles we're LeSean yeah you
could let a defensive guy in there and
he breaks his tackle he keeps going
that's what levee anka do if they did
and now you expect James Connor to be
able to do it but their offense on
Sunday night against Baltimore was
stagnant
they hand in the ball off yeah he
couldn't go anywhere and he's not that
big of a threat in the passing go he's
not it's it's again I I know people want
to root for James Connor and I am too
because it's a great story
you know what guy I still like the way
he plays football he's he blocks for
other people really well right and if he
does have a lane he's good but he hasn't
made any any real Wow plays right he
only gets what's there like how we
always talk about he gets what's
available right it doesn't do like oh if
they're seven yards he gets seven yards
that's great but the levy on bells the
Ezekiel Elliot's the Todd girlies in the
world when there's seven yards there it
usually turns into twenty or then it
goes oh damn it might be seventy or
whatever it may be and that's where I
think people are missing that added to
the fact that hey you know Todd Haley
you know let's not forget that Todd Hill
he's a pretty good OC kind of showed his
ass again last yesterday against the
Raiders points against writers so
they're not that he's not there in
Pittsburgh and I think that's another
huge adjustment there they're trying to
make yeah so but you think levian making
the comment he's definitely sitting out
at least ten weeks I had no doubt he has
to come back though at Alette week
eleven he has to because he needs to do
that so he can become a free agent at
the end of the year so that awkward
thing when he comes back yeah do you
think it depends on maybe did you think
it depends on where the Steelers are
that if they really need him to fight to
get in they're gonna be excited but
they're still gonna be harboring bad
feelings they're gonna be angry I think
the players as this goes on are gonna
realize like I bet you the old line and
some of those guys are ready are like
man we shouldn't have made those
comments I would think III really think
maybe last week was the emotion right
right and I think they were fueled just
some everything I know I think they were
fueled from the inside to like I think
the coaches gave some of those alignment
the push to say those things hoping they
would pressure him into it yeah so they
look like the bad guys from that
standpoint but yeah he's not gonna do it
and good for him he's not don't buckle
save yourself and get some long-term
security let's talk about another guy
that we love before we get into your
game film and all that Aaron Rodgers
yeah they beat the bills 22 to nothing
and he says the offense was not
acceptable now made references to areas
where the game plan put together by the
coaching staff failed to put the Packers
in the best position to succeed
and then McCarthy came out today and
said he has a good relationship with
Rogers what do you think I think the
same thing I always think that he is for
one you know he's not physically capable
of being totally Aaron Rodgers yet to
where you know there's a lot of games
like that through the last few years
where the offense doesn't work up the
capabilities but he is so awesome that
you know at the end of the game we go
well he threw for three thirty and three
touchdowns and he doesn't have to make
comments like that my thing with them is
what we know about Buffalo right what do
we know about Buffalo when you're too
simple on offense like we saw them do to
Jacksonville last year if you have
tendencies in certain formations or
areas you throw the football a pitiless
they know he is a brilliant coach in
dropping people in zone coverages to
where you're known to attack in these
formations and to me that's what the
game looked like throughout plus again
there was some big drops by the past
Packers wide receivers again and Jimmy
Graham there was a handful geronimo
Allison dropped a big one I mean Oh
Jimmy Graham dropped a big one so that's
letting them down too and I do think I
bet you the coaching staff played it a
little conservative I bet you they
looked at this game it goes we're the
better team let's not mess this up we
can win this game twenty four to six you
know what I thought about we always
wonder how does Tom Brady take the quote
if Aaron Rodgers was in my system he'd
throw for five 7,000 yards yeah when
when Rodgers here's Tom Brady say that
what do you think Rodgers things I think
Rodgers knows that I think he's
frustrated by that I mean just even
let's think about the things Tony Romo
has said to us about that I mean it's
not a knock on but it's it's yeah yeah I
think he realizes that there's things
going on on other offenses where he goes
I'm not really sure how they're coaching
this or doing this cuz I've never had
these in my playbook but damn these guys
are getting wide open and you know it's
it's not like it's a blown coverage or
anything so yeah I do think there's some
issues there I don't even think Aaron
Rodgers doesn't know what he doesn't
know because he's been in the same
system always and Green Bay you know
after Mike Holmgren it stayed that Mike
Holmgren offense but never evolved and
they've just relied on number four
number twelve to make it happen through
for the last 20 years Chris Brown
tweeted this smart football and I said
it in the group chat and you liked it
yeah if I was an NFL quarterback he
wrote who signed a big second contract I
would negotiate a blacklist of
coordinators play callers that the team
is not permitted to hire and you like
that I mean I do like that because
there's not a quarterback problem in
football there's an offensive
coordinator problem in football and some
of the teams we see continually struggle
it's just recycled bullcrap so yeah I I
was like a big-time quarterback and you
know AG listen organizations they're not
gonna like that but Matt Ryan signed his
new deal and he goes listen listen this
hey and me like 20 times what you're
paying that I see right I don't want to
play with Steve Sarkisian right or yes
or if something does happen with Steve
Sarkisian who I like and I think there's
potential there here's a list of five
guys that I know just through my studies
of being a tenure corner all businesses
work they go Chris
we tried couldn't work out so we brought
in this guy right he's saying you make a
list of offensive coordinators that I
refuse to play for right right yeah no
it's almost more effect no it would you
want a wish list he's saying an on list
oh okay yeah I'm saying I'm saying a
wish list of no though that's what I'm
saying - okay like Matt Ryan going okay
if things do fall apart from Steve
Sarkisian here's a list of five guys
where I don't want them no matter what
go you bring them in our contracts void
or something like that that I know
they're dirt we always say that the
coordinators are really the secret sauce
of every team without question I mean
without question like like if the court
liked the fact that the Kyle Shanahan
Niners with CJ Beathard almost beat the
Chargers is crazy thank you crazy know
that okay let's talk let's just real
quick talk about Thursday Night Football
okay with people getting on Anthony bar
cover so I texted you that said a lot of
people are coming out Anthony bar
because he got beat by Gurley on the
touchdown right and he got beat by
Cooper couple the touchdown by Robert
Wood he got beat by Robert woods and a
lot of people are like man Anthony bar
sticks yeah see that's that's that's the
problem with highlights and football and
things like that that is
and then my and then Zimmer goes this is
I've never had a team cover this bad no
you've never had coaches torch your
defenses bad your ass is being torched
right now by certain offenses
I mean week one it was there to be had
by the 49ers Aaron Rodgers on one leg
torched your ass and if he had to it
would in a way worse and then yeah here
we are a week for her you forgot about
Buffalo well yeah and Buffalo their
offense I'm not gonna give them a pass
on that week because their own offense
torch their own ass that of the fumbles
in their own area but then week four
yeah okay you played the Rams Anthony
bar is very athletic but he's 6-3 to 55
and you have him man-to-man against
Cooper Cup and ku and Robert Woods and
and Todd Gurley like not just manned up
like right at four yards of the line of
scrimmage like Robert Woods is running a
30 yard seam route and you're being
asked to carry him that is horrible
coaching and that's where I don't think
like people realize sometimes that
should not happen you wouldn't see Bill
Belichick playing the Rams going hey
Dante Hightower we'd like you to carry
Robert woods up the seam and we think
you can do it even though you run for
eight and he runs for four that's when
your game plan is stupid and needs to be
re-evaluated you have a theory that half
the NFL's running the same defense isn't
the good offensive coordinators can kill
them i I do I think if you really look
at the Seattle and Mike Zimmer scheme so
named all the coaches that come to mind
right I'm gonna go through them so in
Minnesota you got Mike Zimmer
Cincinnati's running the Mike Zimmer
defense still there okay you got let me
I'm just gonna make sure I don't throw
in Oakland running that doctors running
Cincinnati as well Miami is running
Cincinnati okay the Denver Broncos voto
Cincinnati okay so that's five
d'affaires ride the Zimmer Cincinnati
right so there's five and the Zimmer
shinsen I see and I might hit a few
others here but first let me go to the
Seattle one now the Seattle scheme Dan
Quinn Dan Quinn Seattle Seattle okay
Jacksonville Jacksonville Dallas Cowboys
yep Indianapolis Colts okay let me just
make sure I'm not missing anybody else
um no San Francisco and the Chargers are
both running the Seattle scheme gotcha
okay so there that's
well teams that are running two defenses
they're basically and and and those
defenses even though there are a little
different Seattle scheme and I'm gonna
say Mike Zimmer scheme okay what is the
similarity the similarities still very
it's covered single safety defenses
cover three press bail and the way they
pass off their zones and they're just
are a few little different rules but in
a lot of ways are still very similar and
I also think that's a huge reason we're
seeing this offense the explosion
they're out in the NFL everywhere twelve
four hundred yard passing games through
four weeks there have not been twelve in
a season in the last five years so like
this is shattering shattering shattering
offensive rules the the eight people at
the line of scrimmage the NFL has
switched officially from pick plays
bubble screens Peyton Manning era there
at the end in Denver I'm not saying he
was like that always but Denver Peyton
Manning earth and even with like Brady
there with the Wes Welker bubble screens
those kind of place they're gone do you
notice he you don't really see them in
football anymore because there's eight
guys that everybody's got fast
linebackers now and fast strong safeties
so what is it now so now deep it's going
back to old school of we're gonna throw
the ball down the field and hit chunk
plays you're gonna play single safety
and we can put four people out and four
on three fast break you down the field
so you're telling me you're seeing the
movement so because everything went to
the Peyton Manning short throws quick
throws get into the receiver slot
receiver defense is react and thus we
saw the Seattle boom exactly putting a
lot of speed guys at the line riding one
guy back because most of the passes were
going close exactly and now we're seeing
the reaction wave of offense is taking
shots and those defenses are super
liable super lightly at the top five
defensive chords the terms of yards and
I want you to tell me what their
defenses are number ones Jacksonville it
is that scheme it's that scheme but it's
Jacksonville and it's like once in a
every 15 years type of talent that
they're they're getting away with it I
saw statistic that Jacksonville in the
last two years has had three games of
less than a hundred fifty passing yards
and 50 rushing yards in the same game
and no team has gotten
more than one that's all specially on
Jacksonville's special matter Baltimore
Ravens Baltimore Ravens are running the
Dean pees like you don't know what
they're gonna it's a 3/4 hybrid type of
scheme its unique its unique and on a
weekly basis it's you can't just go oh
this is what they do on 3rd down you get
to the you get it onto the field and
shotgun and third and 10 against a
Baltimore Raven Dean Pease Tennessee
Titans the hell knows who know you're
gonna go what I don't know what the hell
they're doing by the way we know that
they're DC is down Martindale but he was
the linebacker right which I love wink
wink I've been with winking down that's
the man yeah yeah so the DC of the
Baltimore Ravens nickname is wink wink
no why no I mean no I'm not really sure
exactly no but if he got like weird eyes
no he's just like a jolly old fella
that's keeps it real as hell
where's Jays you know yeah he's got some
swag about him yeah awesome and I'm not
shocked that defense is kicking ass not
only because he's a good coach but I
players one up high for him they don't
even have Jimmy Smith back exactly
should be interesting
Washington Redskins or third mineski is
a little bit similar to that kind of
scheme as well and he changes up
basically we talk about it all the time
right
there's Chicago Bears Chicago Bears is
true three for Vic Fangio and a true
innovator a true innovator and yes it's
nothing like the other schemes we talked
about and then cowboys are five Cowboys
are five and I would say this the
Cowboys are running the Seattle Seahawks
scheme and I just want to make sure I
got this right but the other thing I
think you have to take their five right
now okay and that's really good but
they've played the Seahawks yes the
Panthers and the Giants where I'm not
gonna sit here and anoint them the kings
of the world right don't things good I
think you bring an interesting point
though that it's we went through this
three or four years ago where you said
every offense that's running the West
Coast is in the bottom five of the NFL
and it's just because it eventually
trends die that's what happens to trends
you know how many times I saw the
Seattle beater just yesterday in games
on the krauser dita the the post with
the second guy through running the wheel
route up and the outside corner taken
the bait and following the post and he
should stay outside the place we saw
Richard Sherman yell out a few years ago
when they're playing the Falcons and
they got in the scuffle of the sidelines
that play because this deep
the Seattle scheme and the Zimmer scheme
let's say it's so popular that I'm
watching games every weekend going dim
the same five plays are [ __ ] your
defenses up every week it's just they
called them at the right time and you
guys forget about it remember the first
time we saw the play that beats yeah
yeah it's a special moment right special
moment dude Manning it was Peyton
Manning so it was a the Super Bowl
Seattle was that Super Bowl loss it was
after the long it was after Seattle will
Seattle beat in Denver I was saying yeah
that'll beat Denver and everybody was
going Seattle might win the next three
Super Bowls and if you guys remember was
like week one or week two
Denver was facing Seattle and Peyton
Manning led to touchdowns arrives at the
end to almost beat him yes and we had
never seen anyone throw against them
right he had one play where the two wide
receivers one did a post and the other
kind of wheel behind it right and and
Sims looked at me and goes holy [ __ ]
that's how you beat this defense yeah
because you have to [ __ ] with the
integrity of the zone right and that was
the first time I was the first time and
now it's like every phrase every week is
everybody does it was week three the
2014 season and you're right we had to
that point we were like and I worked for
New England in 2012 and that was like
damn this defense is real I mean even
Bill and Josh we were they were like man
you know Josh was like man it's hard to
find plays against this all that and
you're right that game and that whole
game that Seattle defense was amazing
but yes Payton and them got in that
hurry up mode at the end of the game and
they started to expose them a little bit
oh speaking of and I want to go to this
Tampa Bay Buccaneers are announcing they
have a bye this week Dirk cutter says
that Jameis will be the starter in week
six I have a question yeah I read a lot
I read about companies I read about
ideology I read about philosophy and
it's interesting when those two things
come together this is what I don't
understand if you were running a fortune
500 company and I came out and I said we
are making cars we're making cars this
is our future we're gonna go with it for
the next few months we feel really good
and then we started making cars and then
all of a sudden like we just came out
the next day and we're like
we're no longer selling cars the company
would completely flop you can't change
like that what do you eat on musk what
are you doing over here I don't get it
so when you come out and say that Ryan
Fitzpatrick will be the starter for a
long time and then your defense allows
five touchdowns in the first half -
Mitchell true Biscay and you're facing
the number four defense in the NFL with
an MVP candidate and Khalil Mack and
then the guy that you put in to replace
him Jameis Winston throws an
interception on his first play why are
they switching Ryan Fitzpatrick was not
the issue in Chicago it was the fact
that you're Mike Smith defense allowed
one of the greatest offensive
performances to a quarterback that
hasn't done anything the entire season
wait till we get into the notes of that
game but Ryan Fitzpatrick being benched
for Jameis Winston and let me just add
mr. Dirk cutter to enter the NFL season
according to Vegas as the most likely to
be fired coach in the NFL and then after
a week for loss look into the camera and
say that you should be fired the balls
on you and let me just say this anyone
that's been in a relationship that's
been on the rocks you know this that the
person that in the fight that goes just
break up with me has already mentally
broken up they've already looked at the
opposite sex on the subway and gone
maybe I should take that notion they've
already thought about I don't have to
move out my stuff and do all that when
you're in a fight for your relationship
and you go just break up with me it's
already over dirt cutter pretty much
said break up with me I'm switching the
quarterback you're two and two in the
south the Falcons are one in three the
Panthers are two in one
well the Saints look like human and
you're you're switching already and
you're saying fire me holy crap I'd fire
I would fire them and to be honest I
would fire them it's annoying I think
the one thing I'm realizing is unless
you're a franchise quarterback you're
not
to make mistakes that's the one thing
I've started to realize in the other
cell like it does it
unless you're drafted in the top 20 then
damn it you get one shot and if it
doesn't go perfect we're gonna question
you all year just like Case Keenum with
Minnesota last year we're gonna question
them all year everything I mean we were
questioning Ryan Fitzpatrick after week
two we have you thrown for the second
400 our game people were going you think
they'll stay with do you think they'll
stay with Ryan Fitzpatrick only got
blamed for the first half against
Pittsburgh but we're not gonna give him
credit for like the miraculous comeback
I am surprised that it's so quick to
happen I will go back and I don't know
if we talked about this last week or not
I can't remember cuz I talk so much now
I really can't even [ __ ] remember
anymore okay but the other the biggest
clue was on Monday night last week
remember and I thought we had this
conversation but maybe we did on Monday
night last week Joe tessitura and Witten
and McFarland who we know talked to the
coaches our best sources the Monday
Night Football crew they made comments
about the organization still backs
Jameis Winston and what happened would
the uber thing happened a few years ago
and he's not the same guy now and that
must be the belief of the organization
and when I heard that that was the first
time I said oh okay so as soon as he
does slip as soon as he slips up they're
gonna do this now it's unfair he's being
blamed for yesterday you're right saying
it wasn't pretty on his part can we talk
about the defense letting up that no no
but but keep going Mitchell I mean now
Ryan but yeah I mean again yeah it just
does you said after how he played he
deserves until week eight yeah I mean at
least to come after the bye and week
five like I thought there was no way
after of two weeks I thought I thought
this is a week six I was like I think he
bought himself till at least week six I
don't know how you can just pin it on
Ryan Fitzpatrick
other than the fact that yes they wanted
to go this way really in the back of
their mind and this just gave them a
little bit of a nudge to do it I am
tired of coaches needing fear to begin
to be creative yeah that's true there
are some coaches in the NFL like it
anyone at any job yeah that thrives to
come up with new ways to do things and I
always get frustrated with these coaches
that until their back is against the
wall
they actually try but I just want to say
that dirt cutter he is not the guy that
should be the food he does not have the
fortitude to lead an organization if you
are somebody that when things start
going bad you're gonna throw people
under the bus and change positions
you're not the guy do you think Bill
Belichick is going oh no like Bill
Belichick the the walls were falling
down and he was like we're gonna be fine
he never said that's the one thing I'll
always respect about Bill takes the
blame just as much as he doesn't place
the blame really he takes the blame
which is I always respect like unlike
when we were talking about was Zimmer
but the the coverage thing yes like Bill
never does that
cutter okay he took someone to blame
there the only thing I'll say that just
and I don't know this is just this might
cutters hand might be being forced here
that's you can Jay light might have
roster control the ownership might say
no this is what we want to do the true
thing is they're all probably gonna get
[ __ ] they're gonna be in trouble soon
yeah
I know Mike Smith's gonna be holy crap
well do you want it let's get into that
film I mean we're on that guts yeah it's
and you're I've never seen you this
except your eyes are bulging it's
mind-blowing
it's my side is mind-blowing but bucks
deep okay so for everyone catching you
up
we like Mike Smith as a person we do we
find him to be a very good guy right we
were very surprised that he got the
defensive coordinators job with the
Bucks after he was last in the NFL with
the Falcons he doesn't change anything
he doesn't he doesn't really add any
ring no and when I played against them
in 2000 two three four five and he was
the D coordinator of the Jacksonville
Jaguars he's doing the same thing now as
he was then there which is yeah which is
you know mainly zone coverages cover
four quarter quarter half things of that
nature a few blitzes that are as mo yeah
but nothing overly mind-blowing and
certainly some coverage defaults on this
all right so to make this simple
okay first without reading just vocalize
yeah okay thank you you're right you
looked at it you know it thank you
all right this was the this was the key
to the game right here I mean first of
all Chicago came out with a cool little
game plan they were aggressive
GetGo for them they rancher Biscay a
little early got a big run they kind of
jump-started first so I just want to say
well well yeah if we're gonna drag
that's another thing I don't understand
the NFL right now if you're gonna draft
quarterbacks that can run why are we not
designing more run what's the point of
drafting them if they can run like isn't
that part of the reason you drive like I
would argue the same thing with Dallas
and dak Prescott like what's the point
of having this big guy that can run if
you don't is that getting hurt I know
and they don't do it until damn the
seasons on the Brinker we're out of the
playoffs now let's run them now like no
this isn't it time to run him they're
only creative until there's fear yeah
you're right it's it's scary
and or they realize it's a do-or-die
situation like the playoffs then they go
let's do it and there is no next week
you know yeah that's the other phrase
illa but the biggest thing is this tight
end to one side three receivers to the
other side okay that's what this is the
formation you have to know tight end to
one side three receivers to the other
side right so it's a three by one set
and they're playing zone coverage
against this all the time now the three
receivers a mix match it was Taylor
Gabriel it was you know Allen Robinson
to Rico and out there a lot they used to
Rico net receiver a lot right
so they used all these guys but the big
thing at the end of the day was any time
you pretty much saw a huge big play from
that offense yesterday it was that
formation it started out with just a
vertical through the middle for the
tight end for the tight end but it
wasn't the tight end the tight end ran
out route to keep that zone corner
occupied and then they ran middle post
like across the field just a straight go
and then the outside guy ran a straight
go and they stressed the coverage and
they didn't know what the free Safety's
going damn there's the guy going across
the field but there's also the guy
coming right at me and nobody's got him
what do I do
so he throws the Taylor Gabriel are you
seeing around the same play dude they
ran the same no it's not the same play
but they went back to the well on a few
of them but the Seattle beater is what
really screwed them oh I saw Trey
Burton's touchdown I assumed it was on a
cross her no doubt about tarik Cohen the
big pie he had down this island same
thing so they're doing it out of three
people right post the post by the
outside guy the corner
takes the cheese at zone please stay
outside nobody told you to play
man-to-man and cover a motor inside
receivers fills and then they had one of
the other Sneath guys just run like a
stay route or a slant return right that
keeps some of the underneath coverage
there and then they would have the other
guy run the wheel route so are you
amazed what is shocking you about all
this
it's amaze to me that such a simple
formation like that like that's a simple
formation the stand okay it's a good
formation but everybody has it that that
those three concepts that they did
within it could totally [ __ ] up your
zone coverage rules and things like that
and you have no answers for it was like
mind-blowing to me I mean mine boy I
don't know how was it like watching the
film I mean it was like watching it was
like watching like seven on seven I
don't even know what it was watch it was
worse than seven on seven because they
usually cover in seven on seven I mean
he was dropping back and looking at
people and he threw the ball great but
they were wide open to I mean they were
wide I mean he just there was nothing to
worry about so is this a credit to Nagy
or an indictment on Mike Smith I mean a
little bit of both it's a little bit of
both Nagy came out aggressive and that's
what I liked about it it was not like
we're gonna get some slants and some
6-yard routes to get Travis key in to
read them no it was like no we're gonna
run you you're gonna get a gash and
we're gonna attack and we're gonna may
expect you to make some throws down the
field and he designed some things that
just absolutely blew their mind and then
he did things off it so I told you about
that first one but the three verticals
that I cross in the field then he had
the next time he got in that formation
he made it look like that guy was gonna
go across and he went to the corner and
he just they they blew
Tampa's minds to the fact where they had
to come out in the second half when they
lined up in that formation they just
said oh we gotta play man-to-man because
we can't figure this out and they played
man-to-man the game was over at that
point it didn't really matter it was 38
to 3 or whatever but what's your big
takeaway of Travis key my big takeaway
of true Biscay is I'm really glad I mean
he can get some of the haters off him
yes okay
terr Biscay has talent he's never gonna
be Patrick mahomes that's the issue with
this whole conversation is people are
seeing Patrick mahomes and they're going
wait we could have drafted him yeah oh
yeah you drafted too risky I'm sorry
Chicago and Patrick mahomes is going to
Hall of Fame right now alright I mean
but true Biscay is really good he can be
really good and he's continuing to grow
in this offense and it is only game four
in year two in the second system for a
guy who didn't play a ton in college
football either I think people forget
that so all of those things are that
that's points to a guy that's he's still
growing as a player so I'm just saying
don't judge too harshly and I think he
has the talent to be really good and
let's not forget damn there Oh Aaron
Rodgers the greatest we've ever seen
away from being four no I mean that's
another one you want to talk about the
quarterback being blamed the [ __ ]
Bears blew a 20-point lead and everybody
blames it on sure Biscay I don't get it
look.we that the first time I realized
that was the Falcons Patriots Super Bowl
Patriots score like thirty five points
in a row and we're gonna blame the
offensive coordinator right on the one
play right no the defense could have
stopped the Patriots one time six trips
exactly
damn okay so that was that do you want
to get into Pats dolphins sure because
you were so frickin sure got my pass
will you bet $400 on the Dolphins not
only to win but to cover and as that was
unfolding and taking away like the
Tannehill fumble that set up the
Patriots anything the Patriots wanted to
do on offense worked no that's where I'm
gonna say it did not oh this is where I
will give you your all James white and
Sony Michelle you know you and
everything the Dolphins tried to do on
offense did not work no that's that's
that's the key to the game let's like I
know it's gonna save sorry after seven
and we're all gonna go the Patriots
offense and I can't read let me let me
do what my vision right from my point of
view it looked like Tannehill was under
attack yeah and any time they tried to
run to the outside the Patriots were all
over that June it also felt like the
Dolphins got behind and they weren't
able to do some of the stuff because it
seemed like they had to adopt a
traditional passing attack and also like
Tannehill was off yeah from the Patriots
perspective I always saw the big plays
in
Sonne michelle and james white right a
lot of screens a lot of dump offs and
they also made some great plays yeah but
what actually happened in the film I
think the biggest thing for me and this
is my context of game matters the game
was three nothing with 12 minutes left
in the second quarter it's three nothing
Hey the Dolphins defense was all over
Brady and the past concepts there was
nothing he did he was struggling I mean
he was getting hit he wasn't throwing
the ball oh well he threw the
interception
to the one guy down the seam because
they were all over it he was it was a
clear go route with a guy running an inn
cut on the outside yes and he was
following the seam and he goes I'm gonna
pass it off to the safety and Here I am
he got a goal line stand to hold him to
that field goal that was really
impressive yes so they and then the
cordarrelle touchdown was kind of with
some kind of the foot it was the first
time they cracked the code a little bit
when they caught might they caught Miami
and man-to-man and they ran a pick and
they wrote pick it was a blatant plate
and pick but it was within one yard of
the hottest scrimmage which is legal so
he can't get mad at it I mean New
England when we feel like that the most
blatant pick of the day though was Odell
oh my gosh I know I can't believe that
didn't cry I don't know how but either
way yes
so that okay so that goes ten nothing
right and then Tannehill fumbles and
then then yes exactly right the next so
the next they score a touchdown to make
it ten nothing and then the snap which
was it was too hot okay it was a backup
Center first of all because Danielle
Kilgore got hurt I don't know what he
got hurt with but it it didn't matter
that he got hurt because he might as
well not been there cuz he was like he
might as well just been attached to ryan
tannenhill slap because that's where he
got pushed back to every time in the
game so that was an issue right off the
bat but so yeah it's 10 nothing your
defense has already been on the field a
lot in the first quarter and a half and
now they just let up a touchdown drive
and the first play is a hot snap goes
over their head they recovered at the 20
James White James white touch it now
it's 17 nothing you haven't played
horrible on defense you've played really
good you're down and your offense is
doing nothing and keep putting your
defense in these bad positions and
that's just come on you're not gonna go
up to New England and win that way and
then they end it with a Phillip Dorsett
touchdown and then a G right weight
touchdowns 31 nothing exactly right it
was
too much I mean that the the what was
wrong with the dolphins often the
Dolphins had seen 75 yards of total
office that's yeah what was going on
what did the Patriots do this is a -
Patriots defense that got decimated by
Detroit yeah what happened the Patriots
up front and whupped them I think that's
the first thing does this make you
impressed with Detroit's offensive line
or do that was the Dolphins offensive
line just not ready to go
no the Dolphins was number I am
impressed by Detroit's offensive line
and some things I think the other thing
too with the Patriots when Trey flowers
is back in the mix and who was my other
guy that I was gonna talk about I'm
gonna think about it real quick when
Trey flowers is back in the mix and
there was some other guy I wrote down
but I can't think of it right now
Oh Butler number 70 Adam Butler yes when
they're back in the mix there a
different defense they were there last
week no they weren't they haven't been
there a lot early in the year tre
Flowers has had some injury issues so
that adds another element to their
defensive line that they can just mix
and mask combinations a little bit
better Danny Shelton played really good
Lawrence guy played good they pushed
back the interior offensive line of the
Dolphins repeatedly and then the other
thing is is it's like Miami went in just
said we're just gonna run our stuff and
we're better than them and we're gonna
beat him no way they really did and it
was a very I just couldn't get over how
bland the past concepts were New England
was all over them and then New England
started to realize they played one rat
what I would call which one rat is like
you know robber same thing it's the weak
side safety comes down
single high safe its minutes man-to-man
but you have an you have a single safety
deep and then the single safety short
and they're not covering anybody
man-to-man just waiting for officer
reading the quarterbacks eye trying to
discourage you from you know good for
short passing teams short passing teams
or anything crossing like this team to
20 yards down the field well they were
doing nothing to beat man-to-man
coverage like New England ran the pick
play to go what you want to play us
minimal I guess like screw you we can't
let you do this run into your own right
they were doing nothing to help out the
receivers ever let alone they were all
over some of their concepts like and
that was really the biggest key to the
football game they could not get the run
game going because they were getting
dominated up for
did you feel stupid about your bet I
mean I think you know what you know it's
even worse just to add on to my students
tell me that you're at NBC and before
the game you go I think Miami's gonna
win Tony Dungy no actually I walked into
NBC just so you know they opening that
and what up [ __ ] and coach good to
see you coach just making sure I stay in
they go crazy as a coach but this is the
when it was twenty Board of nothing at
half I was like I think they're still
gonna cover
you're an idiot I just don't think
they're good this is setting up for them
to cover so I'm reading between the
Simms lines right now and I'm also
hearing this yeah you still think the
Patriots are in trouble I don't I'm not
gonna hate RIT to win thirty eight to
seven and I think you still think
they're in trouble I'm not I don't feel
like as confident as everybody else does
I don't think I'm not I want to say
trouble I'm not gonna say that but
they're still not the Patriots rolling
machine that we've seen their offense is
struggling
I mean Edelman's back Adam and his back
and they don't big of a deal is that
they need them because they are missing
that little short passing game in their
offense right now I asked you as an
Edelman owner on fantasy right
what's what I expect of elemen when he
comes back I mean I think he'll hit full
speed yo you don't even think there's
gonna be any nothing she's a psycho and
he's been training hard and running all
his jerk routes and option routes and do
the Patriots are they I know you're
gonna get to this yeah or the Patriots
are kind of team where they're gonna
like screw the NFL we're gonna feature
Edelman more know they might yeah I mean
they are to a degree they're also just
like you're gonna want to start them off
yeah they are they're gonna because they
also like Edelman so they're he's their
guy and they want him to work and they
know that him and Tom have this great
relationship but like what have we seen
New England after four weeks
there's 23rd in football on offense I
mean 23rd and they play Thursday Night
Football this week and and and Indy they
haven't played great defenses they
played the Houston Texans who were not
that good the first few weeks now they
played them know you know they played
the Detroit Lions who we saw you know
who was weak to Jacksonville ok that was
a good one I can't say that but then
they had the dolphins yesterday but yeah
again I just it's it's so good there's
still the Patriots I think the exciting
thing for New England yeah tell me it's
freaking sony Michelle Sony Michelle we
talked
about those running back to him get more
than what's there he made some cuts in
the game we're on TV I'm not gonna lie I
was gonna like I honestly wasn't
watching the game mission go on it's
only Michelle just doesn't look quite as
that explosive she was in Georgia but
then when I turn on the film I was just
like whoa man that was an unbelievable
jump cut in like holy cow that was
full-speed he stuck his foot in the
ground and cut out the other side so I'm
I guess what I'm trying to say there is
this the the TV's not doing him justice
all the way so when you say that is
because on the film you see it from the
endzone angle you get to see the total
field of everybody running together and
you can put it into justification of Oh
his speed is a little faster than
everybody else's on film and it jumps
more than maybe TV will at times but
because TV does follow the ball and
whatever else and just I don't know what
it is about it but if the only pops out
more and yeah they were uh they ran the
ball well and this would be my last key
to that miami's D line I still feel very
good about it what Miami did yesterday
was I think in a few of those situations
that New England ran the ball they said
they're not gonna run the ball again
they won't do that this is New England
they're gonna pass their pass happy this
is what they doing and they kind of did
some stunts up front which I think they
were trying to create pressure on Brady
for a past situation and New England
called the right run play it was like oh
you want to stunt to the right we'll
just wash you down to the right and then
Sony Michelle or James White I'll pop
out the other side and dolphins three
and oh they're on their way in the win
in the AFC East Dolphins lose by thirty
to seven it was all a pipe dream where
are you with the Dolphins long-term I
mean dolphins long if you still made me
pick I'm gonna pick New England win the
AFC East I am but I think that they're
gonna be in this race longer than will
be seen in years past and I think
they're gonna be a team like the last
two to three weeks of the year it's just
gonna depend if they can win out or
whatever it is to be that fifth seed or
that's easy confident I'm not giving up
on them their defense has a lot of
things that I like
they really does there they can rush the
passer and they can cover and make a
play crate Minko played great
Xavier Howard played gray yeah you know
the kid Bryce McCain's a player they had
no Rashad Jones yesterday don't forget
that that was a big miss there was
somebody else they missed on their team
yesterday I don't think
Vontae Parker played that could have
helped in a game like that but yeah
overall yeah I'm not as high as maybe
everybody else is on the New England but
it's still going in the right direction
before we get to the Titans I want to
read you a stat in the last three
seasons the Patriots have had 21 30-plus
point games they're number one of the
NFL Saints and falcons are tied for two
they've had 20 a little bit drop off
next the Rams have had 14 games of 30 or
more points and last three see there's
probably like all in the last two years
really yeah
towards the bottom of the list the 49ers
have only done it five times right
Broncos have done it twice over the
Bears Browns have done it once the
Giants have done it
zero other than steak temperature the
only thing that I've really argued about
today is the Giants fans obsession with
Eli Man it's an obsession it's still a
thing
people are still going yeah but the
offensive line isn't good and we're not
sure about this and I just want to see
it when the situation's perfect yeah
Giants fans there is no team in the NFL
that has a perfect situation for their
quarterback what you're mistaking is a
quarterback that's unable to make up for
anything else on their team you're just
not used to it when your quarterback
goes down in a sack and it looks like a
helpless twig in the middle of a forest
fire realize that other quarterbacks in
the NFL could have extended that play
when you see your quarterback unable to
hit a guy open deep that's not because
he was under pressure
your quarterback just can't hit it deep
we have been trying to tell you for the
last two to three years that Eli is part
of the problem and if you want to say
there's not enough good players around
him
I'd say it's because he's one of the
highest-paid players in the NFL he's not
playing at the level he should be
playing for the amount of money he's
making and thus you can't afford better
players Matt Ryan is being paid more and
guess what he's rolling out he's
throwing it deep he's risking his body
he's throwing while he's getting hit
right drew brees getting paid in the
thirty million dollar range as well
guess what ruling out checking swing
moves in the flap he's throwing passes
that don't have to be three yards and
then his all-pro wide receiver makes a
man miss enough is enough enough is
enough it's weird man sell the dream
everybody think now we are not haters of
Eli Manning Romo said in the game
yesterday every frickin pass is three
yards when you have a quarterback that
when he's facing pressure is crippled we
gotta figure something out because it
can't all be the offensive line no it's
not the offensive line is not perfect
and it certainly is I reckon that was
anemic but to me and again I'll be
really excited to watch this film but
just even on TV yesterday there was a
few times where they show that behind
the offense you knows camera there and
yeah okay he's under pressure but I also
go damn there's Odell one-on-one outside
down the field just throw it up throw
him a chance to throw it out there see
what he just do it I mean everybody in
the NFL's do it the receivers are gonna
catch you're getting a positive first
but he's not willing to even take those
chances to take the hit I would abolish
offensive line it's worse than the
Giants offensive line and if you're
gonna say oh you can't compare Eli
Manning to deshaun Watson he's making
three times as much as deshaun Watson if
not more I think four and and he's got a
two healthy AC you know Sean runs around
they didn't really run that much
yesterday no yeah oh but he's got
DeAndre Hopkins Odell's better yeah I
don't know what you're gonna say I know
it's Eli I know Eli's a problem I know
you don't want to look in the mirror and
go but he's got two Super Bowls and he's
Eli Manning and he's really good at like
signing note cards for the front office
it's over
it's been over I know man am I am i
exaggerated or not it's I'm in a weird
spot with this always because I don't
want to seem like the Phil Simms hater
of Eli Manning you know what I and I
hopefully anybody that's ever listened
to us and who knows by now that I do
right I just I hope everybody haters
we're truly just trying to evaluate it
football
utilize a good dude he's funny he's had
some unbelievable moments in his career
but yes I get it constantly whether I'm
at my little boys flag football games or
walking in the office today everything
is about we have to help Eli and this
story is the exact opposite
Eli has to start helping somebody else
on the team out that's the problem and
yeah I don't know it just it's blind
it's blinded by love I guess I die you
know he did win two Super Bowls an
amazing fashion against the New England
Patriots and I get all that but I think
we're able to keep it real because we're
in this business on a daily basis and
yeah I'm with you men I want to say this
though right he's gonna get better
here's why yeah I played the Carolina
Panthers next week Panthers coming off a
bye I think Eli is gonna be in trouble
again it's in Carolina after that now
remember we said they could start off
one and sit right they play Philadelphia
great team to lob it up for Odell -
trust me
I watched jaylen Mills get burned on a
regular basis it's embarrassing a week
after that Atlanta in a dome Atlanta's
letting up 30 points to everybody that's
when I think they finally bust through
the 30 point marker Redskins tough game
at home he'll probably play ok bye week
at San Francisco should put up a lot of
points their home against the Bucks
should put up a lot of points there at
Philadelphia should put up a lot of
points and then he dies at the Bears I
guess the Bears but I'm saying like Here
I am crapping on Eli he's gonna make me
look stupid like five of the next six
weeks because you have to look at the
calendar I know but I'm also saying
think about what they could do with a
quarterback that doesn't have a
crippling fear of pass rush yeah I mean
I know man I know I don't know I'm not
exaggerating no you're not I I think
actually you're being nice too to say am
I correct itself I'm not sure if I
believe that because the Panthers eagles
falcons Redskins the next four I mean
the Redskins are Debrett's gonna be you
know Panthers and Washington yeah but
Philadelphia in Atlanta yeah it's a
comedy now Philadelphia's defensive line
might eat him up but just lob it up
against Jim Schwartz
everybody what are they doing sometimes
alright let's talk about that that
sucked
and I could do a deeper dive in this
game like this is a train watch game
this morning so okay
Mariota in the third and fourth quarter
yeah went 14 of 14 yeah
Mariota in overtime they went on a 16
play 75 yard drive to win the game they
converted three fourth downs one was 15
one was 19 and then the other one was
the win Mike Vrabel put out the field or
Thibodeaux came out ivan actually went
for it john lewis right you texted me
and I was already yelling about it why
is Jim Schwartz blitzing everybody when
like you know that your secondary guys
can't hit can you explain to people why
blitzing everybody upsets us well it
except it it upsets us because a lot of
the times especially with an offense
that's you know not proving itself to be
the greatest show on turf you're giving
them really what they want oh ok I might
you know our offense isn't until all
cylinders let me just look for the best
one-on-one matchup but throw it up there
where and Corey Davis is one of those
guys Corey Davis is this is quietly
becoming a top 10 wide receiver and he
is here is and the Taiwan tailor kids
dangerous too and I you know oh guys I
don't want a lob ball going to against
my defense I know and it's um they just
the Eagles leave their coverage guys
into too many vulnerable positions
especially jaylen meal mills I mean
there's a reason we didn't hear Ronald
Darby's name yesterday a lot because rot
they'd the tightness kept going well
damn but they're gonna play man-to-man
we're gonna go after jaylen Mills not
Ronald Darby so Darby played a good game
because they didn't really attack him
every time they had those type of
situations they went jaylen Mills where
he was on the 4th and 17 when they got
the 20 yards well that was his own
coverage to which I would also go well I
don't know what that coverage was I
don't really know what that was what did
you let them get 20 off back 14 yards
and then not disrupt the guy off the
line of scrimmage or at any point and
then also just let them out leverage you
to the outside to where there's no
corner
I just throw a 15 yard out route like
like hey it's seven ah it's it's routes
on air we're just warming up before
practice that's what it looked like
let me explain to people why that last
place sucked the last play for the
touchdown last play for the touchdown
yeah we got a guess they're like 12 15
plays 15 yards away from the endzone
they have no timeouts that's the key the
clock is running down and you're gonna
blitz everyone and let him throw it
right to the end zone why not let him
catch it around the five and tackle him
I know my crazy no that was that was the
play I think that's where everybody
looked at it was everybody just line up
on the end zone and then tackle if they
catch third and 10 on the 10 and you
bless every you blitz eight only three
one-on-one matchup are you insane and of
course there's nobody there to cover the
guy across the whole field like no
quarter can do that that's again it's
unrealistic asking your defense to do
those shows got away with this against
Atlanta and week one yes he that's why I
feel like he felt embolden to go I'm
gonna win the game he's kind of meathead
ish that way where whenever it's in
doubt it's always the aggressive play
it's like when in doubt if they're gonna
run I'm gonna stop the run like I'm just
so sick of that like it's 2018 [ __ ] the
run it's a passing league get ready for
that okay and that's what he should have
done and yes your point about the
timeout and the management of the
situation you know again that might be
one where Doug Peterson needs to listen
to the PyCon go like now Jim I only want
to rush three here rush three maybe
Mariota will run around in the back of
the pocket for a few second stall them
and waste all the time to throw a
completion at the 2 yard line and like
you said you rally to tackle and then oh
can they have enough time to spike the
ball the Titans have a history of being
tackled one yard short right right ok so
I just think of that was just some bad
clock management when do you ever see
the Patriots to it all up low no I know
it's very rare they might do it like
when you get just get into the red zone
that's where you might see them do it
where they just go let's see if we can
catch them they just got into the 18 and
they might think they're gonna drop back
and throw a nice comfortable pass we'll
try to shock them and send everybody and
see if they're ready for they have a
plan for it the game overall though for
the eagle
geoffery being back is huge Dallas
Goddard is a tough son of a gun yes he
is jordan matthews had a cool moment
when he had the touchdown but what were
the other takeaways that you took away
from both teams are the Titans for real
the three and one their only loss was a
marathon game against Miami yeah they
beat the frickin Texans with Blaine
Gabbert yeah they beat the Jaguars they
beat the Eagles so they beat the Eagles
and jaguars two teams in the top four I
did like the Titans earlier this
offseason they seemed to have the pieces
the defense is playing well jerel Casey
is back to his old ways the secondaries
good is this team for real I mean
they're good I'm not gonna go and like
to say that the cream of the crop of the
AFC yeah I don't feel that way I think
they're really well coached I do say
that I mean they're decent Dean P's is
like one of those guys we were talking
about where it's just he's extremely
creative in his prochik he stressed you
guys out with blitz blitz blitzes
yesterday he attacked your protection
schemes and he found some flaws to where
guys get to run free and you had enough
people to block them but you never he
knew that with this call the right guard
steps down and if we bring this
linebacker
they're not gonna be ready for it and
then Wesley Woodyard running through
untouched and you know Harold Landry was
phenomenal right his Bend bro it is
unbelievable right I mean it's amazing I
told you but I mean they they are they
don't let up big plays for the most part
and they do creative things to get you
out the field I mean what's their
scoring defense at because they're not
scoring a lot on offense and here they
are letting up eighteen point three
points per game on defensive side of the
ball and then on offense or their
scoring total for offense I mean damn
they're 28 the football they're barely
scoring more than they're actually
letting up their scoring 18.8 points
again their sixth in scoring defense
you're there they're there the their one
spot behind the Rams so three good cover
corners I'm not gonna say that they're
like superstars but they're really good
so they can they can risk playing
man-to-man from time to time and go
we're gonna do it we're
to be creative with the Blitz or
whatever and get home um then they are
very great in their zone coverages just
like Dean piece always is and he's
creative with the things he does up
front especially once he gets you on
third down he's he's a handful in third
down because he's just you don't know
what he'll dial up added to the fact
that you know again I don't think
Wednesday's hitting on all cylinders yet
I don't I think wences you know what do
I want to say red zone whence is still
not where he was last year when Brent
Scott once got inside the twenty last
year once was either gonna make big-time
throws or move around in the pocket and
manipulate coverage like Aaron Rodgers
does and then throw the guy that was
hoping that's what he was amazing at and
I think he's a little off in that
category I don't think you know Nelson
Aguilar dropping a few balls hurt you in
the football game and I just Dayton
strapped a lot of balls to they did they
drive especially at the end there with
that big one Corey Davis yeah you know a
ji had a good game but it escalated over
time in the fourth quarter
exactly but it's like it's too few and
far between I think like when the meat
and potatoes of the game was there you
guys couldn't really run the ball that
well you know it kind of came at the end
of the game when they got they've tried
to play pass in a few certain situations
and you broke it
I just weather what question if you got
enough weapons right now I mean I don't
think you guys are going anywhere but
it's hard work on offense Doug Peterson
is good on offense if people think Doug
Peterson's like I had a lot of people
he's not Sean McVeigh or Kyle Shanahan
or Josh he's not he's in maybe that next
group of guys down but I'm just telling
you if we could all sit there and watch
film together you wouldn't be his mind
blown with the offense of the
Philadelphia Eagles they they're they're
passing scheme for my for my liking or
somewhat basic really yeah but I'll
shall Jeffries gonna help big time
oh they nice they need a wide receiver
he's a failsafe I mean at least Carson
has a guy to go okay nobody's open I can
just throw to this big guy outside and
put it on his back shoulder I putted him
up forward to go get it yeah I think the
Eagles had like six drops or maybe the
Titans there's a lot of drop it was a
lot of drops there's a lot of drops
everywhere yesterday I thought what was
interesting was Vrabel came out off to
the game and talked about how he took a
lot of Doug Peterson's aggression where
he actually asked him a bunch of
questions the offseason he learned about
you know
going it for fourth down all that stuff
and then used it against Doug Peterson I
mean they converted a ton we also saw
that in the Indianapolis game against
Houston yeah Frank Reich formerly of
Doug Peterson a lot of people are
talking about right now in overtime the
fact that they went for it on their own
43 with 24 seconds left right and
they're saying it was too aggressive and
it led to the loss yeah it did
first let's also remember that the Colts
were losing by three scores in this game
yeah they had no right to even be in
this game here goes Andrew Luck in full
fledged Anarchy mode looking like Bruce
Willis and diehard taken no prisoners
they get field goals or touchdowns in
five of their last six drives capping it
off with a nine play 85 yard drive for a
touchdown and a two-point conversion
just to send it to overtime so 1 Andrew
Luck is [ __ ] back he is incredible I
love betting on Andrew Luck even when
I'm even when I lose I don't care you
feel like you bet on like this this
crazy man that will not take losing for
an answer right
not only that was there any defense that
dominated an offense for three quarters
more than the Texans on the Colts
yesterday no first half of the first
quarter I was like oh the Colts look
good on office yes and then all sudden
Jadeveon cloudy became Jadeveon again
cloudy had to set yeah watt had two
sacks
clowny fell on a fumble in the end zone
Andrew Luck couldn't breathe and then
the Texans got tired yeah
and Andrew Luck with receivers that you
don't even care about they're not even
on the radar for your fantasy team the
Chester Rodgers of the world like get
out of here ebrill and fumbling and lux
like i don't care i appreciate that you
gave an effort let's keep moving
so here Frank Reich has an offense that
can't be stopped like they've gone up
and down the whole time so I am I guess
I'm one of the only people I like to
call I know it's crazy but here's a
thing if he gets that first down mm-hmm
one more player in field goal
yep what are the Colts playing for
they're not gonna be in the playoffs
maybe that's the point blonde that's the
point they were one in two they're a
team with a roster full of young kids
that that have no idea what's going on
right now they got kids like Darius
Leonard getting banged up they're trying
to win the football game yeah were they
playing for a tie I get it this is not
if this was the Patriots I have an issue
Yeah right if this is the Ravens or the
Steelers or a team that's fighting for
playoff seedings the Jaguars totally get
it the Colts are trying to build a
culture they're not playing for this
year Timmy it goes back to Dirk cutter
they have a plan and they're executing
the plan they're not gonna go you know
what though one two and one looks really
good hmm no because all week they're
gonna be in that locker room right now
go and [ __ ] man they think we can we're
going for the win
we're balls to the wall that's what the
Eagles did in their first year of Carson
Wentz when they finished that year like
eight and eight and they had that
Baltimore Ravens game where they were
going for it on fourth down and the
Philadelphia's roasts and Doug Peterson
I was roasted him too what what are you
doing going for fourth down here the
next year the team was so used to going
for it on fourth down we're so used to
going for it in game tying situations
they were ready for it right Frank Reich
is going for it yeah
and for everyone that's playing to Ty
get over I I feel the same way you do
like listen I wouldn't have done it in
that situation either if you're a team
that yes has a high expectation that are
you lose but but I think your point
about you know culture and and all those
things they have all these young players
on their football team there I think
it's more big picture related right and
he Minds jumping over people right
that's right he is he is he's teaching
his young football team he's trying to
teach them how to win football games how
to go out and key situations and execute
and let's go get the win let's not hope
they mess it up this is a team that in
sick they were a top five pick so the
records sucked or six six pick in the
drift that entered 16 games in the
fourth quarter with a lead in nine of
them
this is a culture of blowing leads late
right not a culture of let's fight to
win there's this notion that any team
can win the Superbowl there's like eight
teams that can win the Super Bowl right
now yeah we already know that and and
the fact that we're judging the Colts on
a winner of loss in week four instead of
like wow they battled back and they're
fighting to win yeah like maybe the
defense
maybe the defense could have come up
with a stop there I don't know no I I
think what you're saying I I let your
logic is like mine though when the game
was over I looked at and said yeah I
mean of course they lost cuz they didn't
make that we know that that's no big
like you know breaking news point there
but I think the point is yes the bigger
picture and that's what we're saying
they're not going to the Super Bowl this
year they're not going to the AFC
playoffs they're playing New England
this week right Thursday night holy [ __ ]
they're gonna lose that okay and yeah I
just look at it that way and just go
yeah he's trying to teach a team with
all these hidden young gems just had to
be battle tested and when these type of
football games and I really think that's
all what I did hate the Blake although I
do to me yeah I was watching the game
very intently right
I watched Andrew Luck stand in the
pocket and sit back and went in stand up
and for you for the first time in like
two quarters to throw a quick throw
Jesse ver right that hadn't happened yet
yeah and anything Andrew Luck is so
dangerous
talk about manipulating a defense and
that's all he did for two quarters I
know he'd run for 15 yards he stand up
and run and then he'd throw it so to do
something that you hadn't done for two
quarters that I didn't like yeah on the
other side Sean Watson look pretty damn
he did right I mean I thought like again
there was a lot of games going on and I
was trying my best to watch him ball I
think you got a better feel for this
game overall and we'll deep into it for
Thursday's podcast but yeah I thought I
saw decisive deshaun Watson I thought I
saw oh I got to get out of the pocket
let me just get out instead of like the
last few weeks where he's kind of sat
there for a few extra hops or he like no
go good almost won it in overtime to
Hopkins with a beautiful year good time
I know and I was like haven't seen a
throw like that no exactly right the one
fork leaps clicking Hopkins keeps
looking and I made fun of
Kikki cootie goes out there 11 catches
109 yards
unbelievable don't know where he came
from yeah Texas Tech but it's
unbelievable sounds right out it's
unreal but but that also felt like the
Texans woke up it could be that's why
I'm actually as you're saying that I'm
looking at Houston's schedule just to go
what is Houston scheduled so they got
the Battle of Dallas this week they got
the Battle of Texas they got the Buffalo
Bills after that David Irving's back for
the Cowboys did that oh my gosh and then
you got the Jacksonville Jaguars man oh
man it's so if their defense can come
alive again you know they they can play
all this a bunch
you said Jadeveon Clowney is back yeah
and we need to start realizing that it
might take these players three to four
weeks like Ezekiel Ali the same thing
you have a theory Zeke
clowny these guys that rest try Biscay
these guys that rest all preseason this
is when they start coming back it's it's
football shape and you know hey
preseason is great and they're getting
in shape but there's a difference
between being in shape and being ready
for four quarters of football shape
Jadeveon Clowney i mean i don't think he
could do much of anything throughout
training camp and OTAs so he was
literally using the season to get back
into the groove of things and yet he was
below average for the first two games a
third game there was a few moments here
and there and then yesterday I saw like
roar get out of my way I'm back in your
face and your luck we always I love I
love that by the way Daniel Kilgore out
for the year
damn he is triceps it was the tribe is
that it was something they are sit-ins
out for the year - mmm big losses the
Dolphins are falling apart often
Zhongshan tree branch and ya know two
more things and we're gonna wrap up one
wrap up kids one being Josh Rosen didn't
beat Seattle but that laser
- Chad Williams and the fourth Hyatt
Josh Rosen was my number one quarterback
coming was yours right and he showed
some serious poise yeah some serious
throws I just don't understand how we
keep letting this happen with Sam
Bradford
yeah but I thought Rosen looked great in
this situation yesterday I did too
again I'm all for rookie quarterbacks
even five with Lamar just his effect in
the game but all five are still
encouraging to me and Rosen who was my
number two quarterback when all said and
done yeah I mean Rosen is a not like a
natural throw of the football I mean
every ball comes out of his hand pure
right it's perfect throw it's you know
even some of the incompletions you go
okay was incomplete but he saw a
defender here so he tried to throw it a
little farther outside he put it where
he wanted to put it you know those are
little clues I look for in a quarter of
I just like with Baker Mayfield like the
Baker Mayfield pick six right we'll just
talk about that real quick okay you know
was that the best decision he ever made
in his life no but wasn't the worst the
receiver slipped he threw it away from
the defender and then the receiver put
his hands up as he was slipping on the
ball best of the year he put it right
where he wanted to put it you know so
that's where I look at you know and then
who else we missing
Josh Allen I mean Josh Hollan again this
is why I said don't be tricked by the
Minnesota game remember I said that last
week I mean there's just nothing it's
still hard if he can't make like oh my
gosh what a unbelievable run and amazing
throw I don't think they're gonna be
able to evaluate because he's got no
tell he's got nothing and thence and
Arnold's playing Jackson right and
Rosen's gonna have we're gonna hit the
same little spots with Rosen to like
where we're just gonna go it doesn't
look good but yeah of course it doesn't
look good yeah but I'll tell you what
I'll take Kirk Fitzgerald rookie seals
Jones and David John's any favor the
bills guys name one yeah I know Charles
clay why Kelvin Benjamin like they're
all slow yeah I know
LeSean McCoy doesn't even have burst
anymore no well yeah exactly he's hurt
yeah I know they did that's a Josh Allen
we're not gonna get a feel for what he
had he's got an offensive line like Josh
Allen is in a lose situation at least
Rosen they got a few pieces out if the
OC can get creative through laugh he can
be dicey he can dissect you a little bit
you liked what he looked like I
definitely liked what he looked like
yes it's funny is yeah I mean I really
did him Baker I thought were I like the
way CJ Beathard looked yeah I'm no doubt
I was cruel to myself [ __ ] drool
PJ Beth it makes you drool honey EJ
better
it's like it's hot bad as I ever felt
from my friend as bad as I ever felt
because Kyle yeah cuz they were not the
better team on the field but they
outplayed the Chargers yesterday and
should have won that football game and
really had some bad breaks I mean
whether it's him getting hit as he's
throwing and it falling right into the
lap of the charger guy or they're at the
six yard line going in and the tight end
it goes off his hands
Kevin King returns it for you know
setting out a touchdown like 70 yards
right they had the big punt return with
the king kid on the Chargers I mean it
just there was a few things that just
men the 49ers know no luck there man
covered the spread though they did cover
Baker two big fumbles in that game but
he's I thought he played really what
dude clear and obvious oh so there were
two plays in the Cleveland Oakland game
that are pretty pretty bad one was the
Browns go to convert a third down and
it's called a first down and then al
river on over rules it which I didn't
even know they were gonna check that in
the booth and he says no actually it's
clear its fourth and in under two
minutes so they can do it causing Hugh
Jackson to punt and then earlier in the
game Derek Carr gets sacked and
seemingly all in one motion he's hit the
ball is free and the Browns ticket to
the house they're going to the house
there's nobody there he's picked it up
and Roman and they blow the play dead
saying he was he in that grasp and I
don't leave you know if he was grasped
he was not the ball was swatted and
there's just a lot of people around but
we're at the point where nobody else
matters in football except the
quarterback he's the only person [ __ ]
all of you everybody else [ __ ] your
coaches you you might get fired cuz this
happened and the defense end tears his
ACL but damn we're gonna protect the
quarterbacks it's really annoying
now the Raiders did get screwed on one
where it looked like Marshawn was gonna
have the run of his career and run for a
touchdown they blew him dead yes write
that one at least made a little bit of
sense the derrick karr sacked fumble was
egregious egregious and the the most
wanted Jon Gruden to get his first one I
mean I I don't know what to say I just
out river on went back to what he did
last year that everybody complained
about you don't overturn the call unless
it's clear and obvious I honestly
thought the spot in the field should
have been moved up a few inches I don't
give a damn that al River on works at
the league office I've watched more
football than al River on I've been
obsessed with this since I'm four and
you can go to any kid that ever grew up
with me high school college now they'll
tell you damn chrissa's about the most
obsessed guy I've ever been around with
football so I've been obsessed I know
where the ball should have been spotted
I
and you can't overturn that Cleveland
got screwed in that game because al
decided he wanted to move the ball three
inches back when he was three thousand
miles away upset mic drop
yeah that's annoying it's just the
between that and the quarterback thing
there it's like they're actively trying
to ruin the sport mmm it's annoying
riverboat al but Cleveland you think so
I feel Cleveland I'm encouraged by I
still by derrick karr yeah that's my
thing too is yeah the Browns got screwed
but like man they blew that game yes
they did
fumbled snap right two of them yeah and
then the other fumbled why he was
throwing yeah right um yeah derrick karr
made some big throws derrick karr just
got to continue to throw with the ball
with arc and pace Amari Cooper woke up
yes all his bad plays come from these oh
I'm gonna lob it out there and place it
in the guy's hands you know that you
know what happens and throws like that
that people miss out on and they don't
realize they catch a ball sometimes and
you might see like Amari Cooper caught a
ball as he was running towards the
sideline and he goes out of bounds and
if Aaron Rodgers are Brady threw that
ball yet and then he can turn upfield
for another 20 yards and that's the
thing again the context of the play
everyone just looks at it goes ah look
at it is a nice 15-yard completion and I
look at it and go that should have been
a 15-yard completion in a 30-yard run
but because he decided to throw the
change-up he had no time to turn it up
the field or he got hit as he was
throwing it and there's just too many of
those throws with me but Derek Carr
right now he's doing a lot of good I'm
just saying I would wish he would just
limit those my last thing is
how do we talk about Andy Dalton hmm
we're gonna do a deep dive on Thursday
okay I wanna do a little bit right now
last year mm-hmm you said you were done
mm-hmm you were done with Andy Dalton
yep we've talked before about the last
16 games with Bill Laser has been
something good he is now three-in-one
mm-hmm
they have diced up the Falcons the
Ravens and the Colts yeah their one loss
being to the Panthers lot of deflected
passes but we the thing Andy Dalton is
the Toronto Raptors Oh 55 wins let's see
how you do in the playoffs Oh Andy
Dalton Oh 10 wins you got to win a
playoff game how do we act how do we
accurately talk about him he's he's a
good quarterback he's doing some things
this year wherever I'm going okay he's
doing more than what's being they're put
on the table for him to get and I still
think hey listen it's been really good
so I'm gonna say two things here I still
want to evaluate further it's week four
and now we're gonna get into teams are
building an inventory on your offense
like this is where I always look at New
England I go up Bill's got four games to
break down now watch Joe cuz if you got
tons of these bills gonna screw you over
and that's what the good coaches are
gonna do so I just wanted I'm just
saying I want to watch that to see but I
think the big thing is their offense
still Andy's making some great throws
I'm not trying to take anything away
from him
but they're also making life easier on
them - they're moving AJ garena ground
it's not just about AJ green on the
outside anymore they got two guys you
gotta kind of worry about now Tyler born
he's become that middle of the field
like you know Michael Thomas marques
colston like he can beat you on the
outside but he's also awesome over the
middle and catches those tough balls and
can do something with another number of
third and long said he himself dough for
yes I know what I know and then okay you
know John Ross who's gonna scare people
on a weekly basis and I think they've
had a pretty creative run game on a
week-to-week basis is there anything
more John Ross than catching a touchdown
at immediately limping off of that I
mean what I was like dude you're just
one brand I
but the bangles have talent they do we
know that Joe Mixon has even played the
last few and I guess the only thing I
guess the one thing I just pump my hand
vantes perfect comes back next week yes
yes I know and they're in and I guess my
only thing with them would be this we've
seen this before we've seen it before
you know they beat the Colts in week one
let's not forget that Andrew Luck and
company we're driving down the field to
win the football game and Doyle fumbled
and I know this sound like I'm being a
hater Baltimore Ravens they whooped him
Carolina there was a few players like I
don't know what the hell their office is
doing yesterday and let's also not
forget the Atlanta Falcons they're
missing some very key people and they're
back seven the Atlanta Falcons saying if
I'm bettin overs I'm taking the Overson
it's gonna be a shootout every week it's
it's the opposite of Falcons two years
ago right whether offense was causing
overs now their defense is causing overs
and Matt Ryan's is balling well Brian
might be one of the five best
quarterbacks in football I'm just saying
that now I'm gonna do my list again here
soon and try to figure some things out
but the way just to my naked thoughts
and before I've actually settled this
like III think it's I might officially
have to put him in that class I've never
done I'm legit proud of him yeah he's
ballin Calvin Ridley man oh all and holy
crap I know I don't know what to say to
you man he's kicking ass you don't just
say anything I know but it's this is
amazing yeah I mean I had my questions
about him coming out well I'm sure
Dallas would love them holy cow you
think man all right we're gonna get to a
lot more we'll get to Thursday it'll be
a really good game shout out to Marv
Maher their kicker for shut now now no
one's gonna bring up the kicking anymore
hit the game-winner yeah the only other
thing I was gonna say about that was
Zeke the fact that it was like a 38-yard
scream pass to win
he had 88 yards receiving great that
they're getting him in the passing game
God two hundred and fifty to a hundred
and fifty two yards rushing 88 yards
receiving Zeke is it's like you talked
about with Eli like if they're paying
Eli all this money then he has to also
do good and you know there's costing
them other players in other positions
well there their team is built on their
offensive line yes that's where their
money is and they drafted Ezekiel
Elliott with the number four pick in the
draft and that's where they're supposed
to win the games and they were cheating
themselves by not giving him the
all the first few games a little birdie
told me that Connor Williams needs to
get more legs and ass yes he does yes
you picked the Broncos to cover tonight
III pick a guess a Chiefs 3531 victory
okay it was a five and a half spread I
think in our show a big time scoring
fest I do because I think Case Keenum he
he not gun shy I mean no he is not he is
gonna let it loose and Emmanuel Sanders
and Demaryius Thomas are gonna get open
and Phillip Lindsey is gonna be a he's
gonna be fun to watch to Patrick Holmes
I know I can't wait and everyone's gonna
be listening being like by the way it
was ten to seven it was really usable
hit us up at Sims and Lefko hit us up if
there are things that questions you have
about your game also hit us up on the
YouTube comments below you guys are
always been awesome for us for Sims
peace out homies vendrick we'll be back
Thursday
Thursday's going to Austin Texas yeah
going to the house the Chris Sims belt
and it's Texas Oklahoma oh man I guess
I'll have to talk about that yeah
forfend Rick Moody and the lef koe man
we will holla holla holla holla holla
holla holla at you later and again
Wednesday night 8 p.m. YouTube check it
out we're gonna have Pat McAfee on the
show which is a lot of fun and we're
flipping people to burn you're gonna
want to check it out see you guys later
peace
[Music]